[Applause]
the question at the beginning of the day
could labour keep the NHS top of the
news agenda the answer would soon
present itself a leaked phone
conversation with John Ashworth
criticising his popularity in his
conversation with a conservative friend
mr. Ashworth also said the civil service
machine would quickly move to safeguard
security if mr. Corbyn became Prime
Minister echoing the conservative mantra
that the Labour leader can't be trusted
Jeremy Corbyn started the day on the
front foot talking about the NHS but
he's really been landed in it by his own
health secretary saying that Labor's
chances are dire and their diet because
of brexit and because of him I was sort
of sort of Weinmann ate up and try and
try give him a census I thought it's
better if I've been football managers
try and wind up the football manager of
the other team in the context of a sod
bit of conversation with you made it
seems alright but obviously when it gets
leaked so a website looks terrible
doesn't it and I'm so sorry about that
but I was just going to wind him up a
bit
in Morecambe mr. Corbyn visited a school
that had its own political cabinet of
pupils perhaps easier to control than
his own then it was up to Carla where he
faced up to Ashworth comments he said to
me it was all about reverse psychology
and banter as in football supporters and
the other person was saying the opposite
about their party and it all got a bit
out of hand it's not the kind of stuff I
would do not the kind of
way I would talk to anybody but John was
called Mae made it very very clear and
you know John has been a fantastic
shadow secretary Stover the health
meanwhile Boris Johnson came up with a
new way of delivering an our familiar
message it's the red wall he'll need to
break on Thursday if he's to get his
majority but he's convinced this slogan
can't do it John Ashworth made
absolutely clear that he thinks the
reason mr. Corbin is failing to persuade
some people today foreign plaintiff is a
large numbers peeled home is he is
blocking brexit but here in pandal a
conservative marginal and leave voting
constituency certainly there were Corbin
faithfuls who put Labour's plans for the
NHS above getting brexit done all things
but it's not enough to make me vote the
virus Johnson Boris Johnson can't me win
me over on any arguments unless he
completely changes his personality but
it's the shadow health secretary who's
punched the biggest hole in Corbin's
campaign today a reminder he hasn't
always had the confidence of his closest
colleagues both men have one day left to
gain the confidence of the British
electorate Jason Ferrell Sky News